- [Voiceover] In preparing for a race,
Jill ran half the distance that Sam ran.
So let me write that down.
So let's say J, is the distance Jill ran,
is equal to half the distance.
We'll say S is the distance that Sam ran.
And Sam ran three times the
distance that Aisha ran.
So Sam ran three times the distance,
that we'll use A for the
distance that Aisha ran.
What was the ratio of the distance
that Jill ran to the
distance that Aisha ran?
So let's think about it.
So here, we have how much
Jill ran in terms of S.
So maybe we could write how
much Aisha ran in terms of S.
Then we could find the ratio
and then the S, it should cancel out.
So let's see, over here
if we wanna solve for,
if we wanna write this,
so we have how much
Aisha ran in terms of how much Sam ran,
we can just divide both sides by three.
So you divide both sides by three.
We're left with Aisha ran
1/3 the distance Sam ran.
So if we wanna find the ratio,
the ratio of the distance Jill ran
to the distance Aisha ran.
So it's the ratio J over A.
The ratio J over A.
This is going to be equal to 1/2 S.
That's what J is equal to.
Over 1/3 S.
That's what A is equal to, over 1/3 S.
So it's equal to 1/2 divided by 1/3.
The S is cancel out.
So this is going to be equal to 1/2.
You divide by 1/3, that's the same thing
as multiplying by three over one.
And so, one times three is three.
Two times one is two.
So the ratio is equal to...
So the ratio the distance
that Jill ran to the distance
that Aisha ran is three to two or 3/2.